be safe and how to have to move on and
so we were able to build capacity
because the whole reason I did 25
executive orders in Oklahoma was to
build capacity in our hospitals and also
the PPE and we were able to do that and
really flatten that curve and that was
our objective and I told Oklahoma's the
the better they they do in that period
of time the quicker we can start
reopening and that's exactly what we've
done and Oklahomans are being safe and
we can see it in our numbers but we're
ready to get things back to normal get
life back to normal so again we can't
wait to have you in Oklahoma on Saturday
great job Kevin thank you thank you very
much Joe Peter please and also to be oh
thank you and also to be able to visit
many businesses throughout the states I
traveled to North Carolina as well as
Dallas and visit with the faith-based
and the lending community as well as
some small businesses too to feel and
see and as evidence of how PPP is
actually working not only in the
faith-based not only in small businesses
but also the lending community what more
can we do to facilitate more capital for
the small businesses the underserved
committee communities are also being
sought after we've asked the lenders the
very diverse lenders that we've signed
up over 50 400 of them to provide
outreach very aggressive outreach to our
inner cities and underserved communities
I've spoken with some of the governors
I've spoken with the mayor's as well
that we need to do more there's over a
hundred billion dollars available
remaining in the PPP program a very
successful program you've shared Laurie
that how you've been able to transition
your business from a very high end to
take out and still maintain the customer
base and we're realizing this mr.
president throughout the states and
every state that we visit now the fact
that SBA has been able to have a touch
point of over 10 million small
businesses we have 50 million that you
indicated of employees in one court
and another about 9 million in the other
portfolio so at some point we will be
providing technical assistance providing
some coaching and counseling to be able
to solidify those relationships that the
new businesses have developed with the
lending community so I thank you
president thank you very much and you
know they've done like more business in
four days than they did in four years
it's a big kids become a big business
small business is now big business so
thank you
thank you and a great job thank you very
much Steve please mr. president thank
you it's a pleasure to be here and it's
great to see your economic programs
working especially for small businesses
the PPP has been a tremendous success
we've seen that in the employment
numbers we still have more work to do we
want to make sure that every single
person who lost their job because of it
gets back to work and we won't be done
until that happens and I'm also pleased
that this week working with the Federal
Reserve we've opened the Main Street
funding facility again that will be
accessible to small businesses down to
two hundred and fifty thousand dollar
loans so again a a massive amount of
liquidity that's been pumped into the
system for small businesses Thank You
Larry how are we doing today well on
weekly unemployment claims fell for the
eleventh straight week it's a good sign
kind of job numbers in June and I think
would be very strong I agree with
Stephen I think the rescue plan worked
I think the PPP was superhuman probably
saved 55 million jobs and we saw that
with a three million dollar three
million job increase in the May numbers
I compiled my list of green shoots
served
we've got Apple mobility for traveling
almost back to his pandemic pre-pandemic
high a homebuilder demand and confidence
is very very strong automobiles car
sales are moving from 8.6 million to
12.2 million as the factories reopen as
you noted the retail sales number was a
spectacular 18 percent
Michigan consumer expectations very
strong today NFIB
optimism index expect economy to improve
a record jump expect economy to improve
a record jump and manufacturing the
Philly Fed and the New York Fed future
activity indexes off the charts if I
play reference to the Congressional
Budget Office it will get a 20% increase
in q3 which i think is quite possible
20% increase in q4 and a 5 percent
increase in q1 2021 we will be back to
where we were in 2019 we will have made
up for the lost ground mazing it's not
going to take 5 years
we will made it up with some decent
numbers by the first quarter of 2021
that's called a super V right super V I
like the eyes it's called the V it's
called the V plus well that's where
we're headed but we were headed to great
things and then we got hit by the
Chinese plague so you know that happens
too and things happen that you don't
expect sometimes so but where we built
at once we're now building it again and
it's gonna be even more successful in my
opinion Kaylee please yes mr. president
I would just note that the V is indeed
an AI and you've described this economy
like a rocket ship previously and I
think the numbers you laid out are worth
three emphasizing because it's exactly
that 2.5 million jobs added blowing past
expectations you had the experts off by
about 10 million jobs that's quite an
extraordinary number to be off by also
the Dow above 26,000 points you
mentioned the Nasdaq setting the record
seven million jobs 9,000 opportunities
zones here the jobs president you did
this once you brought 7 million jobs and
quite clearly what the markets are
saying is they have faith that you are
the jobs president that will do this
again so most people have never built a
positive economy we're gonna do it twice
and the second time is gonna be better
than the first I think Steve we have a
shot at it right ok please
yes I'm Anthony Goins and I'm honored to
be here mr. president
representing the state of Nebraska we
were really focused on three things in
terms of making sure that our economy
stayed on track and first it was
stabilization so the PPP the ID alone
gave us the liquidity injection that we
needed to help us out debt servicing our
community banks work very closely with
the small businesses to defer payments
and then we move into recovery and when
we talk about recovery the one point
zero eight billion dollars that we've
received from the Treasury has been a
huge help we've broken it down into four
programs small business stabilization
rural broadband we're given a million
dollars for Gallup and then we're also
looking at taking workers that are in
industries that are shrinking and
retraining them in high-demand
industries so we can put Nebraskans back
to work in the right areas but you
mention rural broadband and we're doing
that very big for the Middle West and
for our farmers and that's a very big
factor and as you know we've started the
process already yes and I think you're
gonna be very happy with it absolutely
thank you so much appreciate it good
afternoon mr. president
governor's secretaries directors and
honored guests my name is Melissa
Haggerty and I'm proud and honored to be
the invited guests of governor Ricketts
from the great state of Nebraska I am a
wife and mother to two young daughters
ages 9 and 11 as well as the co-owner of
four bakeries in Nebraska and Iowa we've
been in business for 10 years and of
approximately 92 employees early on in
kovat 19 we decided not to layoff any
employees rather ask the ones that live
at home with their parents to scale back
on some of their hours if they can by
doing that it would give the other
employees that needed their ships to be
able to cover their rent and other
expenses an opportunity to keep their
hours most of our employees are in their
early 20s with no families to fall back
on so it was critical for us to take
care of them any way we could it was an
important decision for the Federer
government to allow each state's
governor to decide how to formulate
their own plan of how to close and in
turn reopen their state fortunately my
business is in both Nebraska and Iowa
were able to continue to serve our
guests inside the bakery while
practicing social distancing sanitizing
between guests all while everyone wears
a mask
we have several terrible weeks of sales
leading into Easter it was easily the
scariest time of my life as a business
owner not knowing what would happen next
we did apply for and receive paycheck
protection program funds through a small
locally owned bank who we've had a
strong relationship with since we
started back in 2010 that program has
been helpful for us to continue to meet
our fiduciary obligations in terms of
promises to our staff as well as paying
our monthly bills as the virus continued
past Easter we are able to increase our
delivery business while adding a new
service for a guest curbside pickup but
with curbside pickup it did come with
some challenges so increased labor would
be probably the biggest effect on our
bottom line additional employees have
been added to answer the phones and
runners are needed to take orders out to
the guests waiting in their car by
mid-may sales were picking up and we did
have our best mother's day ever seeing
double-digit growth over last year's
weekly sales so my Nebraska bakeries
have now entered phase 3 starting this
upcoming Monday of Governor Ricketts
directed health measures we anticipate
our guests desire to celebrate all of
the life's events they missed over the
past three months
new babies birthdays anniversaries
retirements with our ultimate hope that
it will transfer into a much busier
summer than we normally would have I
want to thank you for inviting me to be
a part of this important discussion
thank you very much great job thank you
very much please
thank you
Thank You mr. president I'm honored to
be here representing small independent
restaurant industry and the great state
of Oklahoma
thank you for inviting me I am a small
independent restaurant editor I own and
operate Stella modern Italian cuisine in
Oklahoma City my restaurant celebrated
ten years in business in April prior to
Cove at 19 I employed 30 people in the
restaurants when restaurants were closed
for inside dining I was forced to
furlough some very dedicated and loyal
employees for the first time ever since
I did receive the PPP financial
assistance I was able to offer all of
our staff their jobs back and all but
three returned I want to thank you and
governor stit for working so hard for
our economy and helping us reopen in a
responsible and systematic way our
industry worked very closely with
governor stit and the Health Department
of Oklahoma on guidelines to reopen with
a phased approach it has been good to
get back to work and to be able to serve
our guests under the guidelines we
adopted in Oklahoma we are using
data-driven points to ensure we are
reopening our restaurants and economy in
a safe in an efficient manner in
reopening our number when goal has been
to keep our customers safe as well as
our employees we know there's work to be
done to create a sense of confidence in
our diners as well as our employees and
help people feel good about dining out
again we are diligently following all
the guidelines on using PPP for I'm
sorry PPE for our employees doubling our
sanitation practice and encouraging our
customers to follow the suggested
guidelines for social distancing
restaurants have always had
outstanding protocol in place for safely
preparing food and serving our customers
in a safe manner as you're aware the
restaurant industry has suffered greatly
during this unchristian prison time our
job loss and loss cells has been
overwhelming so I want to thank you for
working so hard for our economy and
signing into a law the cares Act which
provides PPP forgivable loans to help
our industry and our economy at large
get back to work there is more that
needs to be done and we appreciate the
opportunity we have to work closely with
you your administration and there are
congressional leaders for next steps to
get our economy and our industry back to
work and fully open president throughout
America's restaurant industry is
grateful for your leadership in guiding
us through this pandemic thank you again
for inviting me to meet with you and
thank you for governor still for your
leadership in getting Oklahomans back to
work that's very nice and we're gonna
try and get deductions back for your
restaurant industry and you could look
at that man right over there he'll be
carrying the message but we're looking
for the deductions for entertainment
restaurants and I'll get it
you'll get it right back bigger than
before okay working very hard on that
please Thank You mr. president honored
to represent the lot lodging industry
before America's first hotel your
president grateful to governor's Ted for
his leadership and for the invitation to
join today my name is Pete Patel
first-generation American my family and
I immigrated to the United States in
1979 in search of the American dream
we found that American dream in Tulsa
Oklahoma is small Hotel your small
business and hotel your's our company
owns and operates 12 hotels in eastern
Oklahoma the current crisis lodging was
the first to suffer because of shelter
in place and we will be the last to
recover it may take up to two years
before kovat our industry had record
occupancies profitability and new
development hotels thanks to the
exceptional strong economy under your
leadership mr. president because of
kovat occupancy dropped at 20 percent
nationally revenues fell by 50 percent
and 70% of all hotel employees were
either laid off are furloughed for the
first time in my career we were forced
to lay off employees and that was the
most gut-wrenching experience that we've
had the payroll protection program was a
lifeline to our industry to help
America's small businesses and our
employees the best thing for our
business is that our economy opens
grateful to Oklahoma governor for his
systematic data-driven approach to
leading our state back to opening
currently our occupancies have picked up
a bit but we still have a long ways to
go as an industry as well as our market
the hospitality industry as a whole as
stated our reopening hotels in a safe
and healthy manner the industry has
implemented what's called safe stay
standards
sanitization PPE use social distancing
things like limiting buffets and using
grab-and-go prepackaged items swimming
pools and gyms are limited with
appointments for use guests and
employees are only safe as as how we
make the properties and we have done the
hotel industry has done a great job in
adapting ways to make sure all of our
employees as guests are safe mr.
president I would like to mention a
couple of things we need more states to
reopen consumers to feel safe to travel
industry will need additional resources
to help pay our bills increase cap on
the idle program would be very helpful
to us
and what we need pressure relief from
our local banks who may be stressed in
these times coming up that have
hospitality loans we will need help from
the federal reserve and FDIC on those
two things in conclusion mr. president
America's hotel yers are grateful for
your leadership appreciate we appreciate
and you know what it's like to own and
operate hotels we are looking forward to
working with you towards a swift and
strong recovery thank you
I'm impressed by your twenty percent
number that was your low point you're
better than any hotel company that I've
seen
we had Hilton then there were at one
percent right and we had we had all of
the big ones and they were from one to
four or five percent so if you're at 20
percent
congratulations that's pretty good that
was the average mr. president there was
a few of them that weren't that lucky no
that's great great job Thank You mr.
president thank you as your domestic
policy chief what an honor it is to have
all of these small business owners here
at the White House I'm reminded that
just yesterday mr. president we had
veterans in the day before we were doing
policing reform in the Rose Garden the
day before that we were talking about
seniors and taking care of our elderly
and fraud everything you do every day
every minute is how to do the most for
all Americans and the small business
this is the backbone of our country I'm
from a town of 1,200 people Glen Rose
Texas an hour south of Dallas raised by
a single mom who had a flower shop on
the Main Street of Glen Rose small
business truly is the American dream at
it's very very best and the work that
secretary minuchin that administrator
Carranza are doing for this country is
extraordinary but it's executing your
vision and so bringing today these small
business owners to the White House
talking about how we're going to not
just get this country back where we were
just a couple months ago before the
pandemic from China hit but to even
greater heights than ever before it's
just an honor to be here and I want to
welcome and thank everyone for coming to
the White House and thank you mr.
president for your leadership thank you
for doing a great job thank you very
much okay thank you all very much
mr. president this book I bought this
sooner
why do you keep hiring people that you
believe watch codes and Liars
you
you
you
[Music]